Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to start the discussion at least
about arbitrage. What is arbitrage? In
finance, arbitrage has a very specific
meaning. It's a guaranteed investment
that earns a return higher than your
risk. In other words, it's a money
machine, a pure profit. And already you
can see that it's a dream for the most
part that when it exists, it's going to
be small and temporary. So let's set the
process up by thinking of the essence of
arbitrage.
The best way to think about arbitrage is
to think about two traded instruments
that have exactly the same cash flows.
In this case, think of it as investment
A and investment B. They have exactly
the same cash flows. Exactly the same
cash flows. They have to sell at the
same price. You can see why, right? This
isn't rocket science. Let's say
investment A sold at a higher price than
investment B. Here's what you would do.
You would buy investment B, sell
investment A. You would capture the
difference right now because you know A
is selling for more than B and then
since your cash flows are exactly the
same, they'd offset each other. You have
no risk, no cash flow obligation, and
you keep keep the difference you made up
front. That is arbitrage. Now, that of
course is what I would call pure
arbitrage. two investments that have
exactly the same cash flows that sell at
different prices. For the most part
though, it's going to be very rare. What
you're more likely to find in the real
world is near arbitrage, which is
something close to riskless, but there's
still some residual risk. Things that
are not quite identical, but trading at
different prices. You're taking
advantage of the difference and hoping
that those residual risk that are left
are not large enough to IPO. And then
there's a whole host of investment
strategies that are called arbitrage,
but I would more likely I mean I think
of them more as speculation than
arbitrage because they're risky
strategies. We'll start in this session
and focus mostly on pure arbitrage.
For pure arbitrage, as I mentioned at
the start of the session, you need two
investments which have exactly the same
cash flows. That's going to be tough to
find in the real world, right? It's very
difficult to find identical assets and
assuming they exist, it's very difficult
to think of a world where those two
identical assets trade at different
prices. You know where you're most
likely to find this in in the real world
is when you have derivative investment
securities on a on an underlying asset.
We have options and futures on a stock
and they're trading in different
markets. Sometimes it is possible that
market prices could diverge giving you a
chance of up of arbitrage. It could also
exist in the fixed income market,
especially in the default free segment
because a bond is a collection of cash
flows. It's conceivable that you could
create something that looks just like
your bond by looking at other traded
bonds and perhaps take advantage of
mispricing. Rare, but it can happen. So,
let's start by looking at arbitrage in
the futures market. A futures contract
gives you the right to buy something at
a fixed price in the future, 6 months
from now or a year from now. It's often
on something that is traded right now.
There's a spot price for what you're
trying to buy. And you could buy it and
hold it for the next year and get the
equivalent of what you got in a futures
contract. And therein lies the basis for
arbitrage. There are two strategies you
can adopt if you want to own something a
year from now. It could be a commodity.
It could be an index.
First is you can buy it today and just
hold it or you can buy a futures
contract. A futures contract you just
you know lock in the price and a year
from now you pay the price you get the
commodity. If you decide to buy it today
to make the two strategies equivalent
you'd need to borrow the entire amount.
You would need to buy it today. You need
to store the commodity for a year
assuming it's storeable. And at the end
of the year, you'd have exactly the same
endgame. You'd own the product. But in
one case, you got it by buying a futures
contract. The other by borrowing money
and buying the under the the commodity
today. In both strategies, you end up
with the asset. You have the same risks.
You should have no price risk. You and
if they trade at different prices, you
should be able to capture the
difference. Sounds abstract, but let's
try this out on a storeable commodity.
As I said, this is storeable. It could
be gold, it could be iron, or it could
be any storeable commodity. There are
two ways you can get that. One is, as I
said, you could buy you could basically
buy a futures contract and get the
commodity at the end of the period or
you can borrow money and buy that same
commodity, store it for the year. to see
where arbitrage comes in. Let's let's
specify the arbitrage free condition. In
an arbitragefree world, the futures
contract is not an expected price for
the commodity a year from now. It's
going to be the spot price with whatever
interest rate you'd have to pay to
borrow the money to buy the commodity
today plus the storage cost you'd face.
You see, what? Let's think of a word
where the futures price is greater than
that arbitrage price at ftop. Now the
futures price is is a higher number than
what you got from working through this.
Here's what you're going to do. You're
going to sell the futures contract. This
is going to be a common theme in
arbitrage. You're going to sell the
overpric contract, right? You get
nothing now. You borrow the spot price
today and you buy the commodity. And
I've listed the cash flow. So today your
net cash flow is going to be zero. you
borrow the money. So from your pocket,
you're paying nothing. So it costs you
nothing to create it. Year from now or
whatever the end point is of the futures
contract
because you b you you have the commodity
already. You pay and you paid the
storage cost. You got the commodity. You
deliver on your futures contract. But
during the period that you held it, you
had to pay the storage cost. So set the
storage cost aside. You deliver on the
futures contract. you collect the
futures price and you pay off the loan.
If you look at the collective cash flow
you're going to get here, it's going to
be greater than zero and you took no
risk and you face no cash flow
commitment. So because the futures price
is so high, you've captured the
difference and the two strategies you
adopted offset each other.
What if the futures price is too low?
Well, remember the rule. You sell the
overpriced, you buy the underwear. The
futures price is too low. It's
underpriced. You buy the futures
contract. Cost you nothing. You sell
short on the commodity. Selling short
basically means you sell a commodity you
don't own, but you get the cash flow
today, which is the plus S. You lend the
money out at the risk-free rate. I know
this sounds complicated, but it's all
doable. A year from now, you collect on
the loan that you lent out with the the
riskless rate still playing the game.
So, you you get back whatever you lent
out plus the interest. You take delivery
of your futures contract and you return
the borrowed commodity and you collect
the storage cost because and this might
be tricky know in some case you might
not be but to the extent that you save
that person the storage cost you collect
that storage cost here again you walk
away with a sure profit with no risk and
no investment. So what you're
effectively doing is taking advantage of
the difference between what the actual
futures price is and what it should be
given the spot rate given the riskless
rate and the storage cost with storeable
commodities. It's worth remembering
futures prices tell you nothing about
expected future what the commodity will
trade in the future because they're
locked in to the spot price through
arbitrage.
So you have a futures contract and gold.
Try this out. The futures price should
be the spot price of gold and should
incorporate the the interest rate at
which you can borrow or lend money and
the storage cost. Of course, in the real
world, there might be frictions in this
process. The rate at which you borrow
money, the rate at which you lend money
might not be the same. You might have
two different rates. The storage cost
might or might not be collectible when
you sell short. What that'll do is it'll
not make arbitrage go away, but it'll
create a range of prices around which
there's no arbitrage. So instead of a
single price, this is a range of price.
As long as the futures price falls
within the range, there's no arbitrage.
But if it goes outside the range, there
will be arbitrage. That's for a
storeable commodity.
About 40 years ago, the first futures
contracts on stock indices came about.
Now, if you look at the relationship
here, here again, you have two choices.
You can if you want to own the index a
year from now, you can buy a futures
contract to get the index at a fixed
price, a price you set today. Or you can
buy the index today with borrowed money.
And when you do that, you have a
riskless interest rate you got to pay on
the borrowing. But while you hold the
stock, you also collect dividends on the
stock. So you get a net yield, which is
the difference between the interest rate
and the dividend yield. In fact, the
futures price for an index futures
should be the spot price of the index
and be a function of the interest rate,
the riskless rate R and the dividend
yield. Let's see what'll happen if your
actual stock index futures price
deviates from that that arbitrage free
price. If the futures price of the index
is greater than that F-S star, here's
what you're going to do. You're going to
sell the futures contract. No cash flow.
You're going to borrow the level of the
index in the market and buy stocks in
the index. So the two offset each other.
There's no cash flow today
while you hold the stocks because you
own the stocks now for the next year.
You collect the dividends on the stock.
You deliver on the futures contract a
year from now and you pay back your loan
with whatever you get on the futures
contract because the futures price was
great at the near collective cash flows.
You walk away with a sure profit, but
again with no risk and no upfront
investment. Notice that theme. In an
arbitrage, you have no risk and no
upfront investment. You walk away with
the sure profit. What happens if the
futures price in the index is too low?
Then you buy the futures contract. You
sell short on the stocks in the index.
And that's tricky part in the real
world. We'll talk about what happens if
you can't do that. You lend the money
you get from selling short at the
riskless rate. And at at the end of the
futures contract, you collect on the
loan. You take delivery of the futures
contract and you return the borrowed
stocks. You can already see that index
futures don't tell you what the index
will be a year from now. They basically
are a function of the level of the index
today, the level of interest rates and
the dividend yield on the index.
Of course, with index futures, you might
have real world concerns. The rate at
which you can borrow and lend can be
different. you might not be able to sell
short easily without a transactions
call. So if you introduce those, all you
do is you don't make the arbitrage go
away, but again you create a range for
the arbitrage. As long as the futures
price falls within the range, there's
nothing you can do. But if it falls
outside the range, then you unleash
arbitrage.
Let's talk about T- bond futures. Here
again, you are you have a choice, right?
You can either if you want to own the
10-year T- bond a year a year from now,
you can either buy a futures contract to
get that bond at a fixed price or you
can go buy the bond today and live
through the next year. Right? You
collect coupons and because you borrowed
money to buy the bond, you got to pay
off the interest rate. Here again, I
won't bore you. If the futures price is
higher than that FAR, then you then you
unleash the arbitrage. You sell the
futures contract. You borrow money, you
buy the bond, you collect the coupons,
and those that collection and the cash
flow you get from delivering the futures
contract, you pay back the loan, you
keep the difference, and you reverse it
if the if the futures price is too low.
Already you can see that just like
storeable commodities, financial assets
when you have futures contracts are
bound by this arbitrage relationship.
Finally, let's talk about currencies.
You have currency futures. What is a
currency future? You basically have a
futures contract in this case to buy
Swiss Franks a year from now at a fixed
price. Here again there's an arbitrage
relationship and that arbitrage
relationship is tied to the spot price.
So if the spot index level in this case
is one $1.10 per Swiss Frank, your
futures price will be that spot price
but be a function of two interest rates.
one being a US dollar interest rate
which you can borrow and lend and a
Swiss Frank rate at which you can borrow
and lend. So let's say the spot price is
$110. Let's say the interest rate in the
US market is 2%, the interest rate in
the Swiss market is 1%.
The arbitrage free price is 1.1109
which is the spot price and the function
of the difference between the US and the
Swiss Frank. If the futures price is
greater than that number, here's what
you'll do. You sell the futures.
You go out and borrow the spot price,
buy the by buy the Swiss Franks in in
the so you borrow with the 2% interest
rate embedded in it and invest in Swiss
Franks at 1%. And at the end of the
process, you will walk away with a
schwer profit because of the fact that
the futures price was too high. Futures
price is too low.
Then you buy the futures contract, you
borrow at the Swiss Frank, you convert
the Swiss Frank to dollars, you invest
the$110 in the in the US market at 2%.
In both cases, what you're taking
advantage of is a mispriced futures
contract and the fact that you can
borrow or lend in both markets. So
currency futures are again constrained
by differences in interest rates across
markets. It's arbitrage free as long as
you can borrow and lend at those rates.
Here again, you can create bounds. If
you can't borrow and lend at the same
rate, you can bring them in, which just
brings a range into your arbitrage.
There have been studies that have looked
at whether you can actually make money
on futures arbitrage. A very early study
concluded that you really can't make
much money. In the years since, there
have been studies that find that you can
sometimes make money, but not reliably.
The way you make money is either by
having a transactions cost advantage
over everybody else. Kind of not talked
about transactions cost of selling
short. Maybe you have a much smaller
cost which gives institutional investors
an advantage. Maybe you develop an
information advantage. You're saying
what kind of information advantage?
Remember with stock index futures you
had to you had to the dividend yield
came into play. Dividends are actually
vary across the year. Early on, people
who didn't factor that dividends were
different across months mispriced index
futures. And if you were ahead of the
game and you looked at the pattern of
dividends and brought it in, but it's
temporary. But when you do have a quirk
in the data pricing, you might be able
to take advantage of it, but only for a
brief period.
What about options? Options are rights
to do something rather than obligations.
Basically, a call option gives you the
right to buy something at a fixed price.
A put option gives you the right to sell
something. Options are derivative assets
or which means there's an underlying
asset that is traded. And if you can
borrow a lend, that combination is what
provides the basis for options
arbitrage. So, let's talk about the
different forms of arbitrage can exist
in the options market. Here's the
simplest one. Remember I said with a
call option, you get the right to buy
something at a fixed price. Let's
suppose you have a call option on a
traded stock and the stock is trading at
50 and the call option which has three
month. It's a three-month call option
has a strike price of 40. What does that
mean? You have the right to buy the
shares at 40 anytime over the next 3
months.
If that call option trades for less than
$10, you have pure profit. And here's
what you can do. Let's suppose that call
option trades at $8. You're going to go
buy the call option, exercise it,
exercise it instantaneously because when
you exercise it, you make $10. 10 is
greater than eight. You make the $2
profit. With a put option option, you
get the right to sell something at a
fixed price. Let's assume you have a
stock that is trading at 30 and you have
the right to sell it at 40. A put option
with a with a strike price of 40. That
put should trade for more than $10.
Because there again, if you have a put
option that trades at less than $10, you
can make a pure profit.
That's the easiest opportunity for
arbitrage, but it's also almost
impossible to find because that's too
obvious. Anybody can take advantage of
it. In fact, with exercise arbitrage,
you can tighten the bounce a little bit
to the extent that you have to wait to
exercise.
You could argue that a call option
should always trade at more than not
just the difference between the value of
the asset and the strike price, but the
value of the asset net of the present
value of the stack price. Let's take the
example that that I just gave you. We
had the right to buy the stock at 40 in
6 months. That's in 6 months, right? The
present value of 40 in 6 months might be
only 38. You could argue that the call
option has to trade within more than
$12. And here's why. If it trades at
less than $102, you can buy the stock
today, set it aside, and you'd
effectively get the option, the
difference. You'd make the difference.
The same thing with the put option. The
value of a put has to be greater than
the present value of the strike price
minus the value of the underlying asset.
It widens the bounds on exercise
arbitrage. So that's the first kind of
arbitrage, simplest to exploit, but most
difficult to find.
The second way in which you can think of
arbitrage is by going back to the core
of option pricing. 50 years ago, Fisher
Black and Martin Scholes discovered that
you could create something that looks
just like the option in terms of cash
flows by combining the underlying asset
and either borrowing or lending. Now, as
you listen to me, you're probably
saying, well, how much should I borrow
and how many units of the underlying
stock do I need to buy? That's basically
what option pricing models try to solve
for. And in an option pricing model, a
replicating portfolio has exactly the
same cash flows as the call or put
you're replicating. So if you have no
arbitrage, the two have to trade at the
same price. If they don't, you buy the
cheaper one, you sell the more expensive
one, you keep the difference. That's
replication arbitrage. There's a third
form that arbitrage can take in option
markets. When you have listed options on
traded stock, those options can be you
can have options over different time
periods, three months, 6 months, 9
months across different strike prices.
And you can have both call and put
options. And when you have options in
the same underlying stock, you can
actually find ways to create riskless
positions by combining those options.
Let's take a very simple example using
puts and calls on the same stock with
the same exercise date. Let's say you
sell a call option and you buy a put
option. They have the same exercise
price, same expiration date on the same
stock. Let's see what the cash flows
would look like if you create a position
of selling the call, buying the put, and
buying the stock. If the stock price is
greater than the strike price, you sold
the call, right? So, you have to pay the
difference. So, that's a negative cash
flow. Stock price is less than the
strike price on the call that you sold,
you have no cash flow. If you buy the
put and the stock price ends up going
up, your cash flow is zero. But if the
stock price drops, you keep the
difference between the strike price and
the stock price. The stock is obviously
worth whatever the stock prices. If you
sum up the two, you're going to end up
with K, the strike price as your total
cash flow. No matter what happens,
you've got a guaranteed cash flow. If
it's a guaranteed cash flow, that cash
flow, the present value of the riskless
rate should be the present value of that
strike price. That is put call par. The
value of the call minus the value of the
put assuming they have the same strike
price and the same expiration date
should be the difference between the
stock price and the present value of the
exercise price. If that's not the case
again you lock in the difference and
you'll have a riskless position that
delivers a guaranteed profit. That's put
call parity. Extending this out to other
options you have option with different
strike prices. They should follow a
pattern. Right? You have a call option.
As the strike prices go up, the value of
the call option should decrease with put
options. As the value of the strike
price goes up, put options should get
more valuable. So there should be a
pattern. As co if you take a call option
with a given strike price and you extend
the life of the option, the longer life
option should be trading for more than
the shorter life option. If you get a
chance, you might want to check out
option prices on a given on, you know,
and make this listed options on a traded
stock. Check check check it out across
time. Check it out across strike prices.
See if you can find obvious mispricing.
My guess is you won't, but no harm
looking. So with options, you can see
arbitrage in many different forms. You
say, what about fixed income? Fixed
income securities lend themselves to
arbitrage for a more easily than equity
for a very simple reason. They have a
finite maturity date, a day of reckoning
where there's a mispricing, you have no
place to run.
So, let's keep this riskless because it
makes things easier. If you gave me a
10-year T-bond, and I assume T- bonds
were riskless, I know exactly what the
cash flows will be for the next 10
years, and I know what the face value of
the bond is. I could go out and buy a
one-year T- bond, a two-year T- bond, a
three-year T- bond, and if I make them
zero coupons, I can effectively build up
something that looks just like my
10-year T- bond by combining 10 other
zero coupon bonds out there. You can see
where I'm going, right? If I can create
something that looks identical in terms
of cash flows, it has to be priced the
same. That is at the basis of fixed
income arbitrage is you're creating a
combination of bonds that has exactly
the same cash flow as the bond you're
trying to replicate and they're
mispriced. You buy the cheaper one, you
sell the more expensive one. You already
can see why I had to make it riskless
because the m minute minute you bring in
default risk that becomes a bit of a
wild card because that's tougher to make
go away. If you want to create pure
arbitrage with corporate bonds, I think
it's going to be very very difficult to
do. You're saying, you know, one way
people try to get around is a triple B
corporate bond and a tripleB corporate
bond are the same. But are they? So with
default risk, you have that added
dimension that can make your arbitrage
much more difficult to deliver. There
have been studies that look at fixed
income arbitrage. And let's cut to the
bottom line there. Know the potential
for arbitrage profits seems to be fairly
small.
And when they exist, they tend to be
temporary. One of the interesting things
that a study found is that if there are
returns around fixed income arbitrage,
it's usually when a new type of bond has
been created and people are trying to
grapple with how do I price this bond. I
remember the early 1980s when mortgage
back securities were first traded,
people struggled with one aspect of
mortgage back securities, which is
repayment. that people might sometimes
repay their mortgage early and that can
affect your cash flows. And until they
figured it out, there was mispricing in
the mortgage back security market that
some people would be able to exploit
because they learned a little faster
than other people. So, one suggestion I
would make if you're interested in fixed
income arbitrage is go back in history
and look at new types of bonds being
created. Inflation index bond, mortgage
back securities, treasury strips. Early
on in the process, you'll find people
making money because people are still
learning. It takes them a while. But
once you learn, it becomes very
difficult to continue to make those
profits.
So let's look at the determinance of
success of pure arbitrage. The nature of
pure arbitrage. two assets with exactly
the same cash flows, exactly the same
life, you know, trading at different
prices is so difficult to even visualize
that it's difficult to find. So, if you
find a pure arbitrage opportunity before
you jump in, test it out. It might it's
sometimes when things look too good to
be true, they're too good to be true.
There's something that you're missing.
But if you do find it after all your
research of pure arbitrage, lock it in,
make your profits, but don't make it the
basis for what you're going to do for
the next 10 years because often that
that opportunity got was temporary and
you have to move on to something else.
It's also worth noting that when you get
deviation pure arbitrage, those
deviations are going to be small. We're
not talking about 50% deviation. We're
talking about 1 or 2%. Which means to
make money on pure arbitrage, first you
got to do it on scale. You can't make
money with pure arbitrage investing a
thousand. You got to invest a hundred
million or a billion. And second, you
got to keep your execution cost so small
because if your pure arbitrage profits
are small, you can't afford to have
trading costs that exceed those. So
generally speaking, pure arbitrage is
not something that individualist
investors can aspire to. But even among
institutional investors, it can't be the
basis for a long-term investment
philosophy because you're going to
continually run into that arbitrage
opportunity disappearing as other people
learn and learn to price things better.
I hope you found this session useful and
I thank you very much for listening.